l'onu resserrent l'étau autour de moscou
le conseil des droits de l'homme qui
siège à genève a lancé une enquête afin
d'examiner les atrocités reproché aux
soldats russes en ukraine
majorité écrasante seule la chine et les
vitres et ont voté contre l'amendement
l'enquète va se concentrer sur les
violations des droits de l'homme dans
trois villes de la région de kiev entre
la fin du mois de février est le mois de
mars dernier les preuves irréfutables de
violations flagrantes et systématiques
des droits de l'homme ainsi que de
crimes de guerre et de crimes contre
l'humanité commis au cours de
l'agression russe contre l'ukraine
s'accumulent à chaque minute de cette
guerre les responsables ukrainiens
affirment avoir enregistré plus de dix
mille cas de crimes de guerre beaucoup
des atrocités allégués n'ont été
révélées qu'après le retrait des forces
russes de certaines zones où ont été
découvertes des fosses communes et des
corps gisant dans les rues comme dans la
ville de boudhha il y aura 14 ans
faisait du vélo avec son père au moment
ils sont fait arrêter par des militaires
russes son père a été tué
après ça le soldat a tiré sur mes main
levée
mais la belle s'est glissée entre m'ont
poussé mon index il n'a fait que frôler
mon pouce dans la région de kharkiv dans
la ville de ce type en qui ces habitants
ont accusé les soldats russes d'avoir
tiré sur une maison pour eux le 27 mars
ma fille et d'autres personnes buvait du
thé ici en sortant de la cuisine ils
sont vu un char russe devant la porte
ils se sont précipités dans la maison
pour se cacher d'abord pointé son canon
là et quand ils ont commencé à bouger il
leur a immédiatement tiré dessus quatre
personnes ont été tuées ou blessées dans
le cadre d'une enquête sur les crimes de
guerre le parquet de car qui va exhumer
des corps alors que les procureurs
continue de rassembler des preuves le
cren s'apprête à tenir son premier
procès pour crime de guerre celui d'un
soldat russe de 21 ans accusé d'avoir
abattu un civils non armés